und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber einen
schönen guten abend morgen also morgen
entscheiden regierungschefs von bund und
ländern wie es weitergehen soll mit der
korona bekämpfung nach mehr lockerung
sieht es weiß gott nicht mehr aus im
gegenteil
spezialisten der universität des
saarlandes haben ihre rechner mit den
aktuellen daten gefüttert kommt jetzt
sofort incidents 100 wieder ein shutter
und wie im februar
dann würde die zahl der korona toten
sich wahrscheinlich so entwickeln
bei optimaler impfung rote kurve müsste
man dann mit circa 9000 weiteren toten
rechnen bis ende des sommers bei weiter
schleppenden impfungen blau mit deutlich
mehr wenn man abwartet und erst bei
einer inzidenz von 200 anfängt
zurückzurudern
dann wird es richtig schlimm da sind
folgen schwerer und schwerster
erkrankungen noch nicht dabei natürlich
sind das berechnungen ohne gewähr und da
werden wir gleich noch mal nachhaken
aber das beste was wissenschaft gerade
bieten kann
es kommt ganz darauf an was politik
jetzt daraus macht patricia wiedemeier
berichtet es ist wie so oft vor den
treffen im kanzleramt jede seite lässt
ihre papiere ihre vorschläge kursieren
erst der entwurf der spd geführten
bundesländer dann am abend der des
kanzleramtes und demnach soll der
shutdown verlängert werden bis zum 18
april zudem ist von nächtlichen ausgangs
beschränkungen die rede
in landkreisen mit einer sieben tage
incidents über 100 parteiübergreifend
hatten sich im laufe des tages mehrere
ministerpräsidenten gegen lockerungen
ausgesprochen
da das virus sich bedrohlich ausbreite
wir müssen jetzt überlegen ob wir aus
der dritten welle die stark da ist eine
endlos welle machen oder ob wir
versuchen konsequent durch ein
konsequentes corona management diese
welle wieder in den griff zu bekommen
deswegen ist meine dringende empfehlung
für montag keine weiteren öffnung
schritte eine konsequente umsetzung der
regelung
so genannten notbremse und vorsicht in
den nächsten wochen einen shutter und
also bis zum 18
april der handel halte das nicht mehr
lange durch man müsse die grundlagen für
die maßnahmen ändern zb die auslastung
der intensivstationen einbeziehen
fordert der städtetag ich fürchte
einfach das dann fantasielos es weiter
so morgen beschlossen wird und das
können wir nicht sagen wir brauchen
glaube ich die perspektive der ganzen
situation wir brauchen einen neuen
orientierungswert von incidents von
belastungen der its von der impfquote
bis zur sterberate muss das neu
eingestellt werden
auch der traum vieler über ostern
endlich mal wieder sonne strand und meer
zu sehen für politiker und
politikerinnen ein albtraum der urlaub
auf mallorca ist gefährlich dort ist
schon die brasilianische mutante
festgestellt worden und wir sollten
lieber vor ort bleiben in der eigenen
heimat und einen kleinen urlaub
ermöglichen als dass jetzt alle durch
die welt reisen den osterurlaub im
eigenen bundesland verbringen kontakte
dafür werben die drei nord länder
fordern einen sonderweg
zitat nur innerhalb des eigenen
bundeslandes soll urlaub in
einrichtungen mit selbstversorgung und
eigenen sanitären anlagen zum beispiel
in einer ferienwohnung oder ein
ferienhaus in einem campingwagen
beziehungsweise wurden mobil zulässig
sein
zudem schlagen die spd geführten länder
eine quarantäne und tests pflicht für
reiserückkehrer aus dem ausland vor
unabhängig davon wie hoch das
infektionsgeschehen im urlaubsland ist
also auch für mallorca urlauber wo die
inzidenz derzeit unter 30 liegt viel
diskussionsstoff also für die morgige
runde mal wieder im kampf gegen die
pandemie haben die regierungen von bund
und ländern schon jetzt in grundrechte
eingegriffen wie nie zuvor in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik
dabei darf nichts auch kein bios die
verfassung außer kraft setzen
die würde des menschen ist unantastbar
steht da aber eben nur die würde alle
anderen freiheitsrechte auf
berufsausübung begegnungen und austausch
mit anderen
auf reisen und gottesdienste schule und
unterricht müssen immer abgewogen werden
gegen andere rechte
da gibt es keinen absoluten vorrang für
das recht auf leben und gesundheit und
das heißt lockdown auf teufel komm raus
weil damit doch leben gerettet werden
könnten
das erlaubt das grundgesetz nicht der
rest ist umstritten
unser rechtsexperte felix zimmermann
sortiert die argumente leben zu retten
jeder tote ist zuviel recht auf leben
seit einem jahr steht das recht auf
leben aus dem grundgesetz im fokus der
politik einer politik die sich
maßgeblich an corona statistiken
orientiert dafür werden grundrechte wie
etwa die berufsfreiheit die
kunstfreiheit die religionsfreiheit und
die allgemeine handlungsfreiheit massiv
eingeschränkt staatsrechtler josef franz
lindner fordert ein umdenken wenn wohl
der abele gruppen bald geimpft sind das
virus dadurch an todesgefahr verliere
müssten bürger mehr eigenverantwortung
erhalten die eigenverantwortung führt
dazu dass der staat grundrechts
einschränkungen zurücknehmen muss denn
der einzelne hat er die möglichkeit sich
selbst zu schützen nur da wo er die
möglichkeit nicht hat es sich selbst zu
schützen
dort kann der staat und muss der staat
mit maßnahmen eingreifen
stichwort masken die korona als
lebensrisiko akzeptieren maßnahmen
zurückfahren fordern so manche
polizisten und bürger wenn ich rausgehe
begebe ich mich halt in gefahr wenn
nicht drin bleiben wir bleiben schon
sicherheit dass jeder selber die wahl
wie er damit umgehen möchte die ich
arbeite auch im einzelhandel und ich
sage ich will niemanden zwingen in den
laden zu kommen aber wer möchte der
sollte gefälligst auch dürfen
das problem eine corona infektion ist
eben keine reine privatangelegenheit
viele bürger haben was kontakte und
ansteckungsrisiko angeht keine wahl für
staatsrecht lerin anna katharina mangold
ist der zeitpunkt für mehr
eigenverantwortung angesichts der
dritten welle noch nicht gekommen
jeder bürger sei ein gefährt selbst wenn
wir nur einen geringen anteil von
schweren verläufen haben die gesamtzahl
dieser schweren verläufe doch dazu
führen dass das gesundheitssystem
zusammenbricht und das ist der grund
warum rechtliche regelungen im moment
den einzelnen auch untersagen
in eigenverantwortung gefahren
einzugehen lassen sich mit dem hinweis
auf einen drohenden kollaps des
gesundheitssystems freiheitsrechte immer
weiter vertröstet aufschieben
der ehemalige vizepräsident des
bundesverfassungsgerichts ferdinand
kirchhof fordert eine größere beachtung
anderer grundrechte es ist sicher
richtig dass jede dauerhafte schädigung
und jeder tote ein fall zuviel ist ich
glaube da wird niemand bestreiten dass
wir bei diesen bekämpfung und wie im
straßenverkehr auch nicht auf null
kommen ist aber glaube ich genauso klar
also geht es darum möglichst einzudämmen
und das möglichst heißt gucken wir auch
auf die anderen freiheiten die die
menschen bauen
man kann eine gesellschaft man kann eine
wirtschaft man kann persönliche
beziehungen auch zu tode schutz der
staat muss leben schützen doch nicht um
jeden preis
immer wieder locker und da
verfassungsrechtlich keine dauerlösung
sein
da sind sich die staatsrechtler einig
konflikte um leben und freiheit
entscheiden nichts könnte für politik
und bürger schwieriger sein
doch die menschenwürde verlangt dass
hinter der analyse von felix zimmermann
standen lange gespräche mit maßgeblichen
verfassungsrechtlern die in unserem
grausamen nachrichten geschäfte am ende
weniger zeit bekommen als die argumente
verdienen das lässt sich aber heil auf
zdf heute wo die drei
verfassungsrechtler in ausführlicher zu
wort kommen
interessant ihren gedanken zu folgen
es würde schon helfen wenn diese debatte
auf der basis stabiler fakten beruhen
könnte fakten das sind die dinge die
dich weg gehen wenn man aufhört und sie
zu glauben die zu erkennen wird zur
wissenschaft wenn es in einem
dynamischen geschehen um die zukunft
geht professor dirk brockmann erforscht
und lehrt dynamik von epidemien an der
humboldt universität in berlin
guten abend herr brockmann wie berechnet
man dinge wie schule und bildung für
kinder oder den seelenzustand von
familien nach einem jahr pandemie ja es
gibt natürliche aspekte bei der
modellierung diene die nicht so einfach
zu berücksichtigen sind
sie haben einige genannt wir versuchen
halt in den modellen zu berücksichtigen
wie die fallzahlen sich entwickeln
aufgrund von kontakten auf grund von
mobilität aber solche gesellschaftlichen
prozesse sind dann natürlich schwierig
zu berücksichtigen
man hat den eindruck dass solche schwer
fassbaren werte wie zum beispiel
geistige gesundheit einer familie oder
auch zukunftschancen für junge leute
eine ganz geringe rolle spielen
verglichen mit diesem index in der
inzidenz wert der das maß aller dinge
geworden ist auch für das besprechen der
ministerpräsidenten und kanzlerin morgen
wieder maß aller dinge
und diese zahlen schwanken zum beispiel
steht er fest wenn man mehr testet dann
werden auch diese zahlen höher
wie kann man auf so was überhaupt bauen
naja also wenn man das
infektionsgeschehen betrachtet dann
schaut man sich natürlich verschiedene
größen an alle expertinnen und experten
gucken sich verschiedene größen an
bei der intelligenz ist es so dass das
eine größe ist die sehr ausschlaggebend
dass insbesondere wenn man die dynamik
betrachtet wenn sich also die fallzahlen
sehr schnell nach oben entwickeln wenn
sie sich alle zwei wochen verdoppeln
dann ist das eine situation die sehr
brenzlig ist und die erzählt eine
geschichte für sich
nun haben wir ja vor einem jahr gelernt
das ist ganz wichtig jetzt die
verwundbarsten zu schützen
die sehr alten menschen oder die mit
gefährlichen vorerkrankungen
aber die sind inzwischen einigermaßen
durchgeimpft ist es dann nicht zeit die
jungen leute mal mehr riskieren zu
lassen wieder mehr freiheit
zur erlauben stadt diesen incidents wert
immer tiefer zu treiben naja wenn wir
uns anschauen welche personen momentan
auf den intensivstationen liegen
das sind 60 bis 80 jährige und sie
liegen da nicht ohne grund außerdem
entfaltet sich das infektionsgeschehen
ja auch in juno und es gibt nur 10 bis
20 prozent der erkrankten entwickeln
aspekte dieser krankheit langzeitschäden
von dem wir noch gar nicht wissen was
sie bedeuten also wir dürfen das auf gar
keinen fall unterschätzen wenn es um die
dynamik dieser infektionskrankheit geht
und deshalb müssen unbedingt diese
fallzahlen kontrolliert werden
nun wird auch morgen möglicherweise
wieder mehr beschlossen um mobilität
einzuschränken
unter anderem ist im moment die rede von
einer ausgangssperre in der nacht von
reisebeschränkungen und so weiter warum
bin eine familie sich ins auto setzt und
geschlossen in eine ferienwohnung fährt
und dann wieder unter sich bleibt warum
ist das so gefährlich für die inzidenz
wörter oder die infektion
wir müssen immer individuelle beispiele
und das was in der bevölkerung allgemein
passiert unterscheiden und da ist
natürlich das bild von einer familie die
in einem blockhaus vierter zwei wochen
bleibt eins was aber nicht repräsentativ
ist wir wissen halt drei dinge müssen
gemacht werden kontakte müssen reduziert
werden damit der wert dieser britischen
b 11 7 variante reduziert wird oder
wenigstens so reduziert wird dass diese
dritte welle nicht so stark ausfällt und
das andere ist halt das impfen und das
testen was sozusagen noch ins feld
geführt werden kann um das ausmaß dieser
dritten welle in der wir stecken zu
verringern haben wir aus der ersten und
aus der zweiten gelernt wie wir ob wir
es schaffen werden jetzt aus der dritten
wieder rauszukommen
das hoffe ich jede dieser welt auch
unterschiedlich aber alle waren
ausgezeichnet durch ein exponentielles
wachstum am anfang was in
unterschiedlicher art und weise auch
kontrolliert worden ist jetzt sind wir
in der dritten welle die es besonders
besorgniserregend weil sie durch diese
variante b 11 7 angetrieben wird deren
reprodukt dr
wert 1,3 ist also deutlich höher als 1
wir haben aber auch impfstoffe wir haben
mit dem impfen angefangen und das ist
sozusagen höchstwahrscheinlich die
stärkste waffe die wir uns feld führen
können indem wir schnell impfen jetzt im
zweiten quartal so dass diese dritte
welle kontrolliert werden kann
das klingt als wäre es zu schaffen
dankeschön doktor bob man bitteschön
es ist schon schwer mit gesundem
menschenverstand zu argumentieren wenn
urlaub im eigenen land reduziert oder
verboten wird und gleichzeitig mallorca
wieder aufmacht die bundesregierung
sieht die insel mit der niedrigen
inzidenz nicht mehr als risikogebiet
deutsche wollen und dürfen jetzt wieder
dorthin auf mallorca sehen sie das mit
einer mischung aus wirtschafts freude
und gesundheits angst berichtet an der
arbeit
sie eröffnen die saison
die radsportler gehören zu den ersten
die den tourismus auf mallorca wieder
ins rollen bringen
für die beiden freunde aus deutschland
ist es auch eine flucht vor der pandemie
in ihrer heimat wo zu den osterferien
statt lockerungen verschärfungen drohen
ist natürlich auch ein grund weshalb
gerade die mallorca urlauber jetzt doch
etwas verwöhnt sind um viele sagen das
darf in dieser zeit jetzt eigentlich
nicht geben was aber doch aus meiner
sicht recht unverständlich ist durch die
konzepte die es hier auf der insel gibt
und durch die tests sind wir glaube ich
relativ sicher und insofern schauen wir
mal dass die zahlen niedrig bleiben es
beginnt mit der einreise bei der ein
negativer pcr test verlangt wird die
deutschen ferienflieger die an diesem
wochenende auf der insel ahnten sind
allesamt ausgebucht und das obwohl die
aufhebung einer reisewarnung keinesfalls
eine reiseempfehlung bedeutet doch die
sehnsucht nach sonne und strand ist groß
endlich wieder also
ich war für ein jahr zum letzten mal
hier und freue mich dass ich wieder
herkommen kann
wir tragen dazu bei dass es den leuten
in mallorca wieder besser geht
denn die pandemie hat die insel in eine
wirtschaftliche krise gestürzt die zahl
der menschen die in armut leben binnen
eines jahres verdoppelt fast alle jobs
hängen direkt oder indirekt an der
tourismusbranche nach monatelanger
unsicherheit gibt es für maria sierra
nun endlich wieder arbeit im hotel am
mittwoch wurde ich von meinem chef
angerufen und er hat mich gefragt ob ich
zurückkehren kann
ich bin einfach superglücklich doch in
die freude mischen sich auch bedenken um
jeden preis soll verhindert werden dass
mit der zahl der feriengäste die zahl
der infektionen wieder steigt die insel
kann sich keine weitere corona bälle
leisten und so gilt eine masken pflicht
und eine nächtliche ausgangssperre
baris cafés restaurants dürfen nur bis
17 uhr gäste empfangen
der wird vom deutschen eck schoss
skeptisch auf die kommenden wochen will
es langsam angehen lassen
ostern ist ja jetzt mal so so auch ein
pilotprojekt eine probe ob das
funktioniert das kann aber auch nach
hinten losgehen
ostern stellt auch die spanier selbst
auf die probe sie dürfen ihre region
nicht verlassen
urlaube und reisen zu verwandten etwa
während der traditionellen semana santa
sind untersagt von den erleichterungen
profitieren nur die deutschen ein
bisschen geschockt bisschen spazieren
gegangen
die stadt angekommen der wunsch wieder
unbeschwert zu reisen ist verständlich
doch ist reisen jetzt auch vernünftig
die es abzuwägen gilt nicht nur für die
urlaubssaison auf mallorca um
entscheidungen in corona zeiten mehr
oder weniger vernünftige geht es auch in
den nachrichten
nach den ausschreitungen bei der
demonstration gegen korona maßnahmen in
kassel gibt es kritik an der überwiegend
defensiven polizeistrategie die
hessische spd moniert ein absolut
unverständliches zurückweichen des
staates statt wie genehmigt 6000
teilnehmer folgten rund 20.000 menschen
dem protestaufruf der querdenker
auflagen wurden massiv missachtet die
polizei hätte konsequenter vorgehen
müssen fordern auch zehnten und fdp
außerdem sollen thüringer polizisten wie
aufnahmen zeigen teilweise aggressiv
gegen gegen demonstranten vorgegangen
seien
die innenminister von hessen und
thüringen kündigten nachbereitungen an
die cdu bundestagsabgeordnete karin
strenz ist im alter von 53 jahren
verstorben
während eines rückfluges von kuba hatte
sie das bewusstsein verloren
gegen sie war wegen korruptionsvorwürfen
ermittelt worden
sie soll gelder aus einer lobbytätigkeit
aus aserbaidschan entgegengenommen und
nicht fristgerecht angezeigt haben
die außenminister der eu werden morgen
über sanktionen gegen das militärregime
in mir
beraten die eu hatte die gewalt gegen
demonstranten mehrfach verurteilt im
reißen die proteste trotz des harten
vorgehens von polizei und militär nicht
ab nach lokalen medienberichten wurde
dabei ein weiterer demonstrant
erschossen
aktivisten zählen aktuell insgesamt 247
todesopfer seit dem militärputsch anfang
februar in australien hat tagelanger
starkregen zu den schwersten
überschwemmungen seit jahrzehnten
geführt
dramatisch ist die situation vor allem
im osten des landes im bundesstaat new
south wales wurden mehrere ortschaften
evakuiert die regierung stuft die lage
als naturkatastrophe ein
auch die millionenmetropole sydney ist
betroffen ein staudamm droht
überzulaufen und meteorologen fürchten
dass es in der region weiter heftig
regnen wird
niemand würde die parteispitze der csu
mit einem ponyhof verwechseln ein mann
der dort über ein vierteljahrhundert
seine karriere bis ganz nach oben
getrieben hat der muss schon raffiniert
genug sein für die höchste politische
kunst aus einer krise eine chance macht
markus söder hat den versuch heute
mittag mit einer blitz pressekonferenz
gestartet masken und andere habgier
affären könnten ihm den ruf des
saubermanns und das aufräumen bringen
der ihm vielleicht bisher gefehlt hat
wäre nützlich für den nächsten schritt
irgendwann berichtet aus münchen der
auftritt zur pressekonferenz sichtlich
ein schwerer gang
die korruptionsvorwürfe stellen die
gesamte glaubwürdigkeit der csu in frage
die partei versucht die notbremse zu
ziehen
wir stehen am scheideweg es geht jetzt
um die grundlegende glaubwürdigkeit
integrität und das vertrauen in die
gesamte partei durch das verhalten
einiger weniger ist schwerer schaden für
viele bestanden
für die csu steht eine menge auf dem
spiel
auslöser alfred sauter ehemaliger
justizminister in bayern
viele sehen in ihm eine graue eminenz in
der csu
sauter hat als anwalt einen vertrag
entworfen für einen masken deal mit dem
gesundheitsministerium
nun hat er zugegeben zusätzlich ein
weiteres honorar für dieses geschäft
erhalten zu haben von rund einer million
euro ist die rede
hinsichtlich des in der öffentlichkeit
kolportierten vorwurfs eines zusätzlich
zum anwaltshonorar geleisteten
geldbetrags war von anfang an
beschlossen die nach abzug aller steuern
verbleibenden nettoertrag gemeinnützigen
zwecken zuzuführen
alles legal sagt alfred sauter seine
mitgliedschaft in der landtagsfraktion
der csu will er erst einmal ruhen lassen
abgeordneter will er aber bleiben die
csu schwenkt um wie die regeln für
abgeordnete drastisch verschärfen
maximale transparenz wie sie da sagt
dazu gehört zum einen ein absolutes
tätigkeitsverbot für bezahlte
interessensvertretung
es kann nicht sein dass ein abgeordneter
oder ein parlamentarier
quasi mit seinem mandat im auftrag des
mandats kasse macht und stößt damit eine
grundlegende diskussion an das müsse für
alle mandatsträger gelten sagt der
verein transparency international der
korruption bekämpft
das kann nicht sein dass jemand
abgeordneter ist oder abgeordnete ist
und gleichzeitig interessenvertretung
für den bauernverband für die
pharmaindustrie wen auch immer
das sollte nicht sein das gilt übrigens
auch für ngo bnd und sonstiges auch die
spd will einschneidende veränderungen
wenn die bürgerinnen und bürger bescheid
wissen dann können sie sich ja auch ihr
eigenes urteil bilden und deshalb bin
ich dafür dass jetzt alle blockaden
beseitigt werden und endlich klarheit
herrscht das muss vom ersten cent an
alles angegeben werden so befeuert die
csu will noch aus der not heraus eine
grundlegende debatte die sie lange
verhindert hat und dem ex-minister
alfred sauter wurde gerade ein
parteiausschlussverfahren an
dort sollte er nicht auch sein
abgeordnetenmandat niederlegen
zum sport spannende partien in der
fußball bundesliga gab es heute freiburg
gewannen gegen den fc augsburg 2 0
hertha bsc gegen bayer leverkusen drei
zu null
die berliner damit auf platz 14 der
tabelle vor mainz 05
die mainzer hatten 2 zu 1 in hoffenheim
gewonnen wichtige siege im kampf gegen
den abstieg
der derzeit beste deutsche tennisspieler
alexander zverev hat in acapulco seinen
ersten turniersieg des jahres gefeiert
im finale setzte er sich mit 6 zu 4 und
7 zu 6 gegen den an eins gesetzten
griechen stefan nostitz ipass durch es
ist schweres vierzehnter einzeltitel
seiner karriere auf einer ep tour bei
dem hartplatz-turnier in mexiko blieb
der hamburger in allen partien ohne
satzverlust in der nordischen
kombination hat es fabian rießle zum
saisonfinale noch mal auf platz drei
geschafft der norweger gewann auch den
gesamtweltcup und da verteidigte der
oberstdorfer vinzens geiger seinen
zweiten platz beim letzten saisonrennen
der biathleten im schwedischen östersund
sicherte sich franziska preuß erstmals
in ihrer karriere einen podestplatz im
gesamtweltcup platz drei mit dem dritten
platz heute im massenstart es hat
gestern und vorgestern freude gemacht zu
berichten wie berlin kulturellem leben
man könnte auch sagen einfach der
lebensfreude wieder eine chance gibt da
geht was
mit masken abstand und schnelltest heute
schauen wir auf eine andere auch nicht
ganz keine stadt new york erwacht wieder
in aller vorsicht
johannes hano ist tot
[Musik]
tanz performance vor publikum und
atemberaubender kulisse ein jahr mussten
vögel berglund und ihre tanzgruppe auf
diesen moment warten haben sie auf
diesen moment hingearbeitet
wir sind durch viel gegangen in diesem
winter jetzt ist endlich frühling und
wir sind dankbar dass wir den winter in
der pandemie überstanden haben das war
sehr hart
es ist jetzt ein überwältigendes gefühl
noch immer liegt die sieben tage
inzidenz bei etwa 300 aber new york
erwacht aus einem langen schlaf wahl in
der stadt treten musiker tänzer
performance-künstlerin aufbringen das
leben zurück endlich können wir wieder
mit unserem publikum kommunizieren und
es wird langsam mehr und mehr das wird
gut finanziert von stadt und bundesstaat
new york treten in museen garagen
öffentlichen plätzen oder in der
schaufenster der stehender läden auch
prominente künstler auch unangekündigt
um menschenaufläufe zu verhindern
so will die initiative dazu beitragen
dass die kulturszene überlebt er ist so
new york machen und wenn man glück hat
wird man auch am time square
[Musik]
die stadt fährt langsam wieder hoch
museen und kinos unter auflagen
vorsichtig geöffnet des tores dürfen
indoors seit freitag bis zu 50 prozent
belegt werden
auch am time square sind die geschäfte
offen ohne maske aber geht nichts in new
york er sich die leute nicht sicher
fühlen und kommen sie auch nicht hinter
einladen um einzukaufen
die wissenschaft zeigt dass maske tragen
dabei hilft die verbreitung des virus zu
kontrollieren und das ist was wir new
york entziehen praktisch alle tragen
maske immer und überall auch draußen am
strand ohne murren und knurren wird sie
einfach integriert die new yorker kultur
die sich hier so beschreiben
das waren 34 sachen gleichzeitig
und wenn das stück stoff im gesicht aber
hilft diese energie wieder freizusetzen
dann ist das ein preis den sie gerne
zahlen hier in new york
na das gibt noch einen schuss optimismus
den wir über einen blick in die nächste
woche brauchen könnten da wiedeking
[Musik]
vermeiden sie kontakte zu anderen
menschen
am montag jährt sich dieser aufruf der
regierung und die regeln zur kontakt
beschränkung ebenfalls vor einem jahr
verkündet der erste bundesweite schotter
unter anderem für restaurants friseure
und kosmetik die regeln sollten damals
zunächst für zwei wochen gelten
das erzbistum köln will am dienstag
weitere konsequenzen aus dem missbrauchs
gutachten verkünden und verspricht
aufarbeitung intervention und prävention
dem kölner erzbischof woelki wurde in
dem am donnerstag vorgestellten
gutachten kein fehlverhalten
nachgewiesen
in brüssel werden sich am donnerstag die
staats und regierungschefs der eu
treffen
neben einer russland strategie und der
beziehung zur türkei stehen vor allem
die korona pandemie und die impfkampagne
auf der agenda der eu gipfel soll bis
freitag andauern
licht aus fürs klima der wwf ruft am
freitag zur sauer auf weltweit sollen
bei dieser aktion um 20 uhr 30 ortszeit
die lichter für eine stunde ausgesetzt
werden städte unternehmen und jeder
einzelne können so ein zeichen für mehr
klimaschutz setzen
kleine korrektur wir haben gerade
erfahren der gipfel der europa gipfel in
brüssel findet doch virtuell statt also
nicht nur in brüssel
die lage ist noch so gundula das wetter
wird zum start in die neue woche zwar
trüb aber der frühling kommt sonne gibt
es morgen nur im nordosten sonst bleibt
es oft grau mit etwas sprühregen an den
alpen schneit es leicht bei 1 grad im
allgäu und 11 grad in berlin
dann wird es wärmer am dienstag bis 13
ab mittwoch bis 17 grad dazu immer mal
sonne am donnerstag im norden auch etwas
regen
maria ist nächste woche da mit heinz
zusammen haben sie eine gute zeit wir
sehen uns bald wieder eine gute woche
[Musik]